[Music]
[Applause]
the aforementioned kirk d
cousins the vikings quarterback last
night threw for 292 yards two touchdowns
one interception by the way that not
that interception should not count kirk
because that's not your fault we want to
come up with a new stat
okay um and paulie you want to give kirk
the uh stat
yeah a new stat to protect quarterbacks
it's called rci
receiver complete you know cause the
interception rci
what do you think rci and because that's
not your fault for that interception
yeah you know you just hope that people
have a trained eye and understand that
as they evaluate and and usually the
people inside the league do but
outside the league not so much but
that's okay will you endorse
rci if we come up with a new stat for
quarterbacks receiver caused
interception
i will throw my full weight backing
behind
it yeah what time did you get home last
night i got to my house
at 3 a.m and i probably fell asleep
about 3 15 3 30.
have you seen the kids central time have
you seen the kids this morning
uh no they headed off to uh run some
errands with
with uh mom and uh i slept in until
about an hour ago and then got up
and wanted to join you well what happens
you know when do you
get uh interrogated by the family on
after a game
uh that's a good question you know a lot
of text messages last
night late i try to respond to as many
as i can and then um
uh you know my wife when i get home she
wakes up and she wants to talk about the
game and then uh
you know i'll probably get a few today
but uh yeah the interrogation usually
happens right away
how do you explain this that you don't
win on monday night you haven't won on
monday night
you know it is it is statistically just
a kind of a unique thing
because you look back and and uh you
know i played well in a lot of those
games
um but you know for whatever reason we
just didn't get the win
in nine of them nine straight um so
great to get the win last night but you
know
the nature of monday night football a
lot of prime time games is you're
playing really good football teams you
know a few of those years we were
playing teams that either ended up in
the super bowl or won the super bowl so
uh you know going into those games it's
not like we were favored to win or
winning a blowout and
and so uh it was just good to get that
one last night for sure
what is the development with dalvin cook
that he's sort of taken that next step
into greatness not a good running back a
great running back
well i think first of all he's got a lot
of ability i mean he back in 2017 as a
rookie before he tore his knee he was
having an outstanding year and got off
to a great start
in 18 my first year with the vikings i
think he missed like 10 games
and uh for the sixth that he was healthy
he was really special
and then uh you know last year you know
because he stayed healthy all year was
finally recognized as
an all-pro player um this year just the
same way
i think you know rick dennison our
o-line coach gary kubiak our offensive
coordinator i think they're doing a
really good job
you know with with how they designed the
run game week in and week out to give
him a great opportunity
if you could invest in they were stocks
dalvin cook or justin jefferson
which stock would you invest in which
one's a little cheaper
justin might be a penny stock that you
can invest in right now
dalvin's you know he's like apple or
google
no justin's the real deal as well um you
know it's so great when you draft a
first-round pick when you hit on it you
know you never know i
you know you go through the league now
nine years you know that after the draft
you're kind of still suspicious of your
first second third round pick you say
let's just get to otas let's actually
see them let's see them in real ball in
preseason games and then we'll decide
you know if if they're worthy of that
status and
justin uh you know certainly has shown
he was worthy of that first round pick
and it makes a big difference for our
offense but why is it tougher for
receivers it feels like
to be able to for them to establish
themselves
or they can wash out i mean it's it's
usually one or the other but
what is it about that position in the
nfl
yeah it's tricky to put your finger on
because you you evaluate the college
tape and
and you know you feel like you got the
guy and then you still don't quite know
um i think in the nfl there's so much
more man coverage
the defensive backs really you know are
really clued into covering you
like a glove and uh you know in college
you may play a lot of zone
and you know until you get the nfl it's
hard to know if you can really defeat
man coverage time and again
but um you know justin's just a natural
receiver tracking the football catching
the football comes naturally to him and
he's been really really good after the
catch so
i've been thrilled with what he's been
able to do for us just as a rookie
is a rookie allowed to tell you they're
open in the huddle
well shame on me if i'm not asking you
know for for me i
i always want to get feedback so you
know i'm asking the whole line what snap
count do you want here
based on how you feel the d-line is
playing uh receivers tight ends you know
what routes do you think can get you
open what technique are you being played
with do you think you have this route do
you think you have that route are you
ready for a double move
and obviously the adam thielins and
justin jefferson's of the world are
always open and they're going to always
tell you what you want to hear
but so you have to have a discerning ear
but yeah i'm always asking hopefully and
if not they better be telling me what
they want and what they think they can
do to help us
explain the snap count because it feels
like every snap count is the same count
where the quarterback
just like claps his hands or something
we're seeing this in college in the pros
is there it used to be now aaron rodgers
is pretty good at drawing you off
but i don't know how many other
quarterbacks
are you going at a different count yeah
it's a great question uh we probably
carry a half dozen snap counts a game
so whether that's going you know really
quickly uh whether that's drawing it out
or anything in between you know and
using code words dummy counts
you know ways to try to one one moment
what i say is live the next play what i
say is dead
um just trying to keep a defense from
being able to tee off and pin their ears
back but
yeah the clap of the hand has been a
really good
uh technique that's really started in
college and has made its way to the nfl
and um you know it's a great way to
because you can you can bring your hands
together and not clap them
and to the defense it looks like you are
and so they have to show what they're
going to do so it's a very effective way
to snap the ball if you're in the
shotgun
lamar jackson said recently that he was
playing in a game where he went to the
line of scrimmage and the defense was
basically calling out what the play was
going to be
how often does that happen where it
happens
yeah certainly certainly yeah it happens
i mean you uh you know the question is
can they still stop it you know there
are times where the linebackers say
they're running right here
and it's 32 and you still get the first
down so
uh you know the ball still has to be
snapped and you still got to go make the
tackle but
yeah i mean teams watch film they study
all week long i mean that's our
full-time job so
they're going to guess right or have an
idea you know and and
um you just have to hope it's not every
play do you have a tell
have you been told you have a tell with
certain you know like pitchers
that they'll they'll have a tell and
hitters will pick up something
but have you ever been told that hey
you're giving this away or you do this
on running play or passing play yeah
it's another great question and one that
i'm kind of always asking like during
training camp and we're practicing
against our defense you know coach
zimmer our head coach is a defensive
you know has a defensive background so
i'm always asking them
hey do i have a tell you know is there
anything in my snap count that's giving
away that the ball is not going to be
snapped or is it going to be snapped do
anything with
you know my body language suggest run
pass
um so yeah you're always asking but uh
i haven't gotten a lot of feedback of
anything convincing that
that tells that certainly your opponent
is not going to tell you if they find
one
what is it like to go to the line of
scrimmage now and you can actually hear
the opposing team breathing it's odd
um it's the world we're living in in
2020 uh
but you know i'm calling the play last
night and
i'm at times whispering in the huddle
because i don't want the defense to hear
i mean they're standing there five yards
away just staring at me
and uh i'm always you know maybe to a
fault but i'm you know where they're
gonna read my lips i'm worried they're
gonna
study who i'm talking to and say oh he's
talking to the receiver so they're
throwing the ball or he's talking to the
o-line so they're running the ball
so you know i'm always trying to kind of
play that game within the game playing
and play out anybody talk to you last
night hello max say anything
yeah the bears uh you know they talk
throughout the game they play with a lot
of energy they're a good defense
hicks likes to talk a little bit doesn't
it yeah yeah no he was having fun and uh
um well wait how do you know he's having
fun
like now he's just got a big smile on
his face you know during tv timeouts
he's talking to our team to to dalvin
and
actually one of our reserve lineman
brett jones
played with him in college in canada so
he was saying make sure you say hi to
brett jones for me so
he's just talking the whole game you
know all in good fun oh so there's no
smack talk
it goes both ways you know i mean it's
uh it can get heated too
but uh at the end of the day you know
when the game's over you shake hands and
say hey you know you're great players
and you're a great defense for a reason
and we got to see them again in december
so
you know you don't want to to uh you
know say anything to too strong
you're a religious person you ever said
to somebody hey watch your language on a
field
that's a great question uh no i don't
think i've
tried to parent anybody on the field uh
but sometimes you know if i feel a guy's
you know not getting back to the huddle
that's really what i get
uh paranoid about is you know i got a
play clock to operate with i only got 40
seconds to call the play so if you're
gonna go
you know chatter with a player and not
get in the huddle i can't call the play
that gives me less time at the line of
scrimmage so i
i scolded dalvin one time last night for
not getting in the huddle fast enough
oh but i could see that where somebody's
gonna say i'm gonna rip your bleeping
head off and then you say hey
clean up the line yeah
[Laughter]
i'm sure that's going to go boy that's
great trash talking what did he say to
you
he said that's not nice yeah you don't
want to let him uh
you know see them get in your head at
all so you uh you just say
you know nothing or uh or just kind of
smile and wave
uh i know you got uh did you have your
breakfast cereal today you got your uh
cereal that you're uh yeah yeah i didn't
have it this morning but
uh it's been fun to partner with hyvee
and have this
cinnamon m-i-n-n for minnesota cinnamon
snaps
nice that we're uh selling in hi-vs
right now for uh for a limited time
during the season and
all the uh sales you know the pro seeds
will go to uh
boys and girls club here in the twin
cities so it's a great partnership
great to talk to you kirk
congratulations and we appreciate your
time hope the family is well thank you
appreciate it good to catch up blessings
to you guys that's kirk d cousins
winning for the first time in 10 career
monday night starts as the vikings
prevail
over the bears